bootleg head podcast
we got two special guests this is the
first time we've had multiple guests on
the bootleg kit podcast
two close friends of mine they just got
a a
incredible body of work that they
dropped was it last month
almost two months ago now right mid june
right yeah
blaze with us too denmark let's get that
mic a little closer to your mouth
okay cool
[Laughter]
anyway what's up guys peace bro what up
brother thank you for having us
of course man you guys are fam um i was
telling denmark this the other day like
this is a great body of work
thank you bro yeah thanks now you guys
went through
smoker's club shout out to the homie
johnny shipes like that was kind of
i know that that's kind of like a new
offshoot of like what cinematic does
what is like what was the motivation
behind like working with smoker's club
for this project
besides the fact that both of you guys
are degenerate stoners
well i've been a fan of uh smokers club
for a long time i always wanted to be a
part of the festivals but they had great
tours and [ __ ]
they had a bunch of things going on back
in the day um
and when i found out that they wanted to
start releasing music i thought it would
be dope to just kind of mix what we got
going on with what they got going on
because they're on the east coast right
here on the west coast
so we thought it could be a dope blend
and then you guys
creatively i mean when you when you
broke away from funk volume or when
everyone broke away from funk volume
rather
and you started still moving denmark was
i want to say the first artist you
announced right
yeah as a part of the crew um
what is like your guys's relationship
your guys's friendship you guys have
made so much music together
i think a lot of fans just automatically
associate you guys together like
um it's got to be super easy to just
like knock out a project right it's just
like probably natural like
i feel like we toured we spent a lot of
time like out on the road together and
we just
kind of picked up the habit of just you
know
getting off the tour bus on days off and
rent studios
so we can smoke and chill and make music
and i feel like
once we got into the studios and we
started making music we like first off
this [ __ ] is fire
and it's really easy to create facts
that's fair
it's almost like i got the vibe of like
method man and red man blackout
like the new era of that with this you
know what i'm saying like it just had
that energy you know what i'm saying
that's the vibe we was going for yeah
you know
when font volume was still going i was
trying to get dimmer shining default
volume
so that's kind of like one of the last
things that i was trying to do
before the label dismantled so you know
just going over into still moving was it
was kind of already happening that way
so the vibe was already there we was
already vibing off of each other so
being able to bring it back for a second
time that that's just purely being on
the road
being inspired looking at how the fans
were responding to the first one
hey man it's been four years maybe we
could give them another one
you know and that's kind of that's kind
of the motivation i wanted to talk to
you guys about like
each one of you guys have storied
independent careers
um like demeric obviously i think the
first time i met you you were
be real's hype man this was like an o
nine in boise idaho i think
i think busy bone was supposed to be on
the show but he was super late
yeah and he ended up not showing up um
by the way wild busy bone story to share
with you about that night because i
ended up having to pick him up for the
airport later and we did like a little
offshoot like
show across the street it was that guy's
interesting to say the least
um but obviously you have a story to
independent career
dizzy like i remember being in vegas and
when you were dizzy d flashy and you
know you kind of had like the youth like
turned up in vegas and
you know uh then you transitioning from
that to dizzy right and doing smoke out
conversations and your funk volume run
um how how are you guys
able to like sustain what's going on
with the covet [ __ ] not being able to go
on the road
like what are some of the ways you guys
are are
are i guess innovating to kind of keep
keep bread coming in on the music
[ __ ] because i feel like a lot of people
who don't who are artists who
might not necessarily have uh be the
smartest with their money
probably are like having a rough time
right now because
you know a lot of artists depend on that
bag you know what i'm saying to hit yeah
if you burn through the bag and and you
was you was uh
planning on other tourists coming right
up you might be in a bad spot right now
yeah you know what i'm saying but i i
think uh
for me it's just about getting
consistent you know
it's it as far as like always going you
know doing a project and going out on
the road doing two tours and then coming
back and getting something else together
and just kind of like keeping the
process going
you know i realized that the battles
really won in the studio so it's about
locking into the studio and seeing
what i could create there now that i
have more time on my hands you know to
just
take out take away the road [ __ ] double
double down what about you dizzy like
obviously you got your store that's
going like you got a lot of other [ __ ]
going on but like i do feel like
you've you've done a really good job of
like navigating the indie game
throughout your career
and even like since the funk volume [ __ ]
kind of went away because i know that
was still independent per se but like
i feel like you've done a great job of
like building
like monetizing your brand independently
since since that
had kind of gone away you know what i'm
saying like what what are the things
that you would kind of
give pointers to artists who are
watching this like
even [ __ ] the covet [ __ ] put that to the
side just like
being independent like what are the
things you think that that you might
might see other artists making mistakes
with that you might have learned from
even
mistakes that you might have made that
you learned from yeah 100 percent
actually me and demick had a
conversation last night that kind of
like um relates to this question a
little bit and it's like having a
balance
of knowing when you're doing something
for your soul and knowing when you're
doing something for the bag
you know and um
all the bags ain't worth going to get
all the bags ain't gonna be good for
your soul
and some of the things that's good for
your soul ain't gonna give you a really
good bag
so you gotta have that balance on being
able to figure out
you know what keeps you going what keeps
you driving like
what keeps the wheels turning really and
for me it's always
you know of course creating music i'm
always planning ahead so i'm always
that's the one thing that the kova [ __ ]
kind of did to me it kind of prevented
me from being able to plan ahead which i
wasn't
i haven't been used to that ever since i
got in the game and i've been navigating
i'm always thinking three steps ahead
right now so i'm never running into that
that time period and kind of looking
around and figuring out like what i need
to do
but more just like you know having a
plan in place so when i get there you
know i know exactly what i'm doing so
for me
it's just really about like um creating
the music side of things
and um and use utilizing this time to
work with different artists and be
inspired by
um different artists and you know we're
all on different levels so
it could be somebody bigger that can
inspire you somebody smaller that can
inspire you but
you know figuring out that hunger
finding that hunger and running with it
i wanted to ask you dizzy because you
had like a there was a stretch right
where you were on the freshman cover
and the phone volume [ __ ] seemed to be
doing
very well because the warner situation
had happened and your album
i think you were the only per were you
the only person who ended up putting an
album out through warner officially
or did one of hobson's album come out i
think one of hobson's came out yeah
um and by the way warner dropped the
ball on your album because i remember i
couldn't find it at best buy
yeah they did i was trying to go buy
like buy out best buy and i was like bro
what the [ __ ]
they did and with the girl hitting lee
harold like bruh
yeah the coldest part is that they told
me that it was gonna be
a real roll out right like it was gonna
be in i wouldn't even have told people
they could get it at best buy if you
know they didn't gas me up but you know
it's just trials and tribulations
i wanted to ask you man because like i
feel like
there was there's uh you know at a you
were i remember
i think the the i want to say the last
time i might have saw you live
uh was with logic in orlando
whatever tour that was whatever logic
tour that was was that for a second
album
i think under pressure for his first
album yeah
um but i'm curious like no that was an
incredible
incredible it was a true story yeah
incredible incredible
um but i'm curious man because like
you've obviously done records with some
of the biggest artists in the world
and like with the funk volume thing
imploding and then you having to kind of
figure this out for yourself
moving forward i'm sure you could have
at that point in time probably gotten a
deal if you wanted one
and and did the major label thing which
would have been new to you kind of right
but you decided to kind of just hunker
down and and stick to the independent
[ __ ]
like why why that as opposed to you know
trying to go get a deal with atlantic or
whoever the [ __ ]
yeah because i i like i don't have
sometimes i feel like i don't have the
same desires as some of these other
artists like
i didn't really want it all too fast uh
getting it all too fast kind of makes me
nervous
uh i grew up with the bare minimum so i
feel like i know how to maneuver off of
what feels to me like a lot right now
even in the independent game i feel like
the love
the traveling to being able to create
the music it's what i want to do
being able to work with different
artists and like having a range
a wide range of like um sounds that i
can tap in with different people and i
just feel like this is what i wanted
you know it don't it's not as glamorous
from the outside looking in but you know
i make good money i own my masters
you know i'm intact with my soul my
spirit you know
and i do what i want you know i can move
at my own pace like if something is
if something don't feel right i could
pull the plug you know but i can also
take chances you know i can like i like
being in control of when i can
when i want to like maybe take a chance
go out on the edge a little bit
and just that kind of like slow-paced
grind so i've always been
i guess like content bro with being
independent and watching it grow
slowly and just every year is something
new whether it's the shrines getting
more shrines or it's the store
and people coming out to the store i
just see like if you just slowly keep
pushing at something
she would just keep unfolding you know i
was gonna say like um
everyone has their own uh successes and
always
we look at this music industry and it's
so superficial right
it's like people will look at you and be
like ah
man like well you ain't you ain't doing
what this person's doing and this
person's doing but
i think success for everyone and and
happiness is subjective
right you don't have absolutely for a
fact and if you think about it a lot of
the stuff with some of these
you know some artists that are signed
you know
it don't when the curtain closed it it
looked a lot different backstage than it
looks in front of state
you know yeah so it's it's like whatever
you feel
comfortable with do you always sometimes
those people don't have the right
control something they a lot of times
they don't have the money
you know you taking money you owe people
a lot of money you know the stakes are
higher you know so
everybody's in your business trying to
tell you what to do and what not to do
and it just depends on how
you want to do this music thing you know
the cool [ __ ] is like
you able to do it it's big enough the
pool is big enough for people to do it
every which way to get to it
and at the end of the day you know it's
your legacy you leave him behind
and how many people you're gonna have
involved with it yeah denmark like you
you've been around
some of the more legendary uh i mean
obviously cyprus hill
you know exhibit serial killer [ __ ] um
dizzy and and uh shout out tj hopper too
man
i feel like every time i see dizzy i
usually see dj hoppa right
sorry shout out to hopper man that's
sorry i just put a new album out too
uh hop in friends part two so go support
that man that's the homie right there
but um what what i mean [ __ ] you were
just telling me like
serial killers four's coming yeah fourth
project man with
with dudes that i you know shout out
exhibit and be real it's like
i just remember wanting to rap for be
real and just wanted to just get into i
was hoping that maybe i could get into
the studio with him and
and do some songs with him to being on
tour with them to
traveling to even tapping into uh
introducing me to the songwriting or the
or the touring and
and all of that type of stuff and then
actually being able to
loop it all the way around to being in a
group with them
and four projects later that's crazy
it's crazy well you said with the four
like you dr dre might be touching
something on the project
i mean you know we'll let that unfold
when it when it unfolds but
uh i'll tell you this maybe twisting
some knobs you know we
shout we shout we shall see but uh but
[ __ ] shout out busta rhymes he on there
shout out
uh snoop he on there and
dj quick's on the record you know and
obviously dj quick that's big
it's crazy for me you know it's like get
being on a
even just being on the record with snoop
and quick and
busting i'm like damn i'm ready you know
i've seen i'm going bar to bar with bust
the bus you know if
it feels good you know one of my
favorite guest verses
or guest songs you ever wear you were on
the faded record with burner and be real
right
i was on uh i was on i wasn't on that
one no you were on another one on that
same album though
was it trump yeah i was gonna say perks
and patron
xanax and patron yeah yo but like
what are some things that you've learned
from being around be real being around
exhibit because a lot of people don't
know man exhibits like
a lot of people be like well what
happened to exhibit but like exhibit is
a boss
on some other [ __ ] he got his alcohol
[ __ ] and his
weed [ __ ] is out of here like that and
he definitely did the movies and the
television
shot xxx stay whatever triple x he was
in
ice cube state of the union i definitely
learned a lot from him just on how to
like move through the game and just you
got to be confident
and get into it and he you know both him
and b real also taught me about
diversifying and having multiple
different things and
even dizzy dizzy's killing it by the way
we're gonna get to the goddamn the dizzy
og
yeah well [ __ ] you know i shout out
shout out gasco because i got uh damn
rick's gaslato and denmark smack tonight
and uh cushco
we got stony point with hoffa selling in
the stores in vegas so
it's like diversifying and tapping into
these different
uh just these different markets that are
natural to
what you do what you do is is a big part
of it
it's like i've been doing this [ __ ]
already for a long time so it's just
about doing it on on the next level and
and trying to make sure that now you're
putting a stamp on it so that
other people could try what you think is
fire yeah i wanna uh dizzy i wanted you
to kind of give me some insight on like
on the on the weed side of [ __ ] right
because you got
your your strain that's doing really
well um i feel like i see a
a lot of dispensaries um i know it's in
a z
i know it's i mean it's everywhere um
what
because i don't think a lot of people
understand how the weed [ __ ] works
like legally yet still it's still kind
of like wait what
like so for you is it like they're
licensing your name
is it another company you're working
with like how hands-on are you with
the strain and and and and the actual
brand and the actual weeders because you
know a lot of times
people will just like license your
likeliness for whatever the [ __ ] right
is that is it like
what is that it's similar to that yeah
it's pretty much like that with a
license
in my name in my face pretty much but
back in
uh 2000 i think it was uh 13 or 14.
i was hands on deck with like helping
create the strain you know
finding the right strain they were
crossing a lot of different strains to
try to find
what would be the dizzy og so
shout out to crown genetics because the
crown og and the king louie is the cross
that we use to get this eog
and it's been that way ever since you
know uh we knew back then that
the wii was futuristic
you know it felt like it was just strong
as [ __ ]
potent and it was like the next level of
weed so we knew that it would it would
um
it would live for a long time so dizzy
oge has been doing
um really great um and now we got the
cookies now we're doing dizzy cookies
oh that's my first strain of cookies uh
so we tapping into something like that
um around here starting in california so
i'm excited man just
taking it a day at a time not moving too
fast you know and really trying to build
the brand you know my face is on it like
your face is on it
you know being able to walk in the
dispensary and see my smiling face
man i'm like i'm gonna push this [ __ ] to
the death for sure
man so it's been cool um for
a lot of fans don't know behind the
scenes i don't know where you're at with
this situation
but i had a conversation with dame and
him and hopson are back
kosher yeah they're back talking there
might be something
happening between them two um not
necessarily music
but something um which i never thought
would ever happen
yeah me and you i mean obviously you're
really close to the situation but you
know i mean you guys are my guys and
james you know i've had a good
relationship with dame for a long time
and i thought that that was like
when he called me and told me that they
were called i was like you're for real
the [ __ ] now i had asked him like
so does this mean the gang is getting
back together right
now this was like a month ago and he and
he had told me that you and him might
have had like some weird energy now i
don't know you and dame
but like what what is that what is the
by the way shout out to jared jaren for
being one of the best people in the
world
um but what is like your interest in
getting the crew back together per se
you hops in and jaren and maybe
even if it's just a song not even like
funk volume coming back or an album like
just a record
something like that what's your interest
in that um i would be
uh i would be down i'm not gonna say
that my interest is crazy high like it's
something that i'm just extremely
looking forward to
but i would like to see it happen
eventually it's crazy because
as close as i was to the situation i
disconnected myself so much
you know when me and dame kind of had
our little falling out
and the energy was kind of weird between
us i completely just kind of
detach myself from all thoughts of
moving forward
in any kind of direction with like funk
volume with that old [ __ ]
yeah with the oh [ __ ] i was trying to
figure out i kind of felt like it put me
in a funk a little bit
because the fans were kind of like you
know i had never did nothing to have the
fans
you know on my page or coming at me with
so much negative energy this was kind of
this kind of happened after the breakup
so it was kind of odd like i didn't do
nothing wrong
yeah it was all kind of new for me you
know new energy so i had to figure out
how to shake that and like do my own
thing
but um i absolutely don't know the
details
about um game and hop right now
like i was supposed to actually i was
going to get with dame a couple weeks
ago in vegas and we weren't able to make
it happen but
he's probably stuck at a craps table
probably
and that man is a gambling man oh yeah
he gets his money you know what i'm
saying but
yeah we'll see we'll see um i definitely
think that it's a
i think it's a beautiful thing to see
hop step into his own you know i know
that he's been doing some soul searching
he's been traveling and i really wanted
that for him as a homie
even back when we were on the same label
together so you know if if he was able
to
like tap into some some higher energies
to make him
you know see things a little differently
and feel better about himself like i'm
off
i'm all about getting around that type
of energy and you and him had recently
kind of
if i correct me if i'm wrong but you and
him had kind of recently
had a uh a resurgence in your friendship
again
as far as communication and like we did
getting on the same page
again like just kind of communicating
like because i feel like there was so
much
man during that time i remember like
that last tour y'all did together
i remember like there was just so much
weird [ __ ] like hobson call it out
crooked eye and all the guys that like
just put you in jared like yeah
we over here catching strings
but like i i had heard that you guys had
kind of reconnected recently and like
just kind of i guess
came to a good place more recently is
that's true yeah yeah there were some
things that i didn't know
about the fallout that wasn't made
really clear to me
that um i found out maybe two years
later
i hadn't talked to hopson in like two or
three years or some [ __ ] like that and
then i finally hit him and asked him a
question
and um from there you know i had
realized that there was
it was some extreme miscommunication
when when funk volume was like falling
apart
so we was able to kind of hash things
out from there and then
um last year um i did go pop up on him
well he actually popped up on me
and a lamb bow
yeah i say i'm on my tour bus but my boy
popped up in the lambo so i was just
super proud of him and we was able to
just you know
get on good terms and uh you never know
man you never know the fans might get
something
is it kind of like a gift in a curse
having fans like that
oh for sure because it's like like you
said it's like yo they're hidden like
like i feel like like those kind of fans
like you know shout out to strange music
or like like those kind of fans are so
crazy yeah i tried to shift away from
those kind of fans actually i kind of
let them
uh weary they self out of the dizzy
right
vibes you know if that wasn't what they
was into because it's like i'm not like
a
ah [ __ ] all the other rappers but we
[ __ ] with you you know
type of dude like i don't want those
kind of fans i want fans that are real
like like music enjoy music and know how
to pick the [ __ ] they like and know how
to stay away from the [ __ ] that they
don't like but i i don't want to be a
part of like
i [ __ ] this person [ __ ] this person but
you to go you know what i mean
it was this but then again you can't you
can't control how people think and you
can't control what kind of fans you have
so you got to kind of roll with the
punches it's just a learning experience
that's fair man um you guys uh
together this new project you guys just
dropped a video yesterday
we did it day before yesterday yeah
don't worry uh has it been hard like
pushing like
obviously putting a new album out not
being able to do the normal [ __ ] you
would do
like has it been hard to like put push
this project the way you want to
obviously you guys [ __ ] with let's look
at me [ __ ] with your mic man
we're in close proximity this is the
first interview with multiple
with three people so excuse us but um
i mean even like shooting videos and
[ __ ] like i remember like march april
like [ __ ] would get frowned
upon if they're doing a video shoot like
you're a selfish
[ __ ] i told this i told this
[ __ ]
we was looking at the situation um
you know i'm in vegas and like we got
this project
and we had this whole plan put in place
you know
we were gonna start shooting videos and
how we were gonna roll it out
and what we were gonna do how we were
gonna get the fans involved
all this [ __ ] you know and then the
pandemic happened and i was kind of like
i don't know
if it's the right thing to do to come
and shoot a video
and then you know we had to kind of
figure out like
do we let this time consume us and then
we like
you know then sitting in a couple weeks
kind of looking like
damn i wish we would have shot that
video at least so we could have
something to promote you know instead of
like
not having anything so we end up pushing
through it but it was weird
it was definitely weird [ __ ] weird
and if you if you even see
the the all night video or the the we
ain't the same
like there's not a lot of people there's
no extra people
in the video you know it was a very
small set we shot with one director
matt alonso and uh you know we
we first one we we rely heavily on the
concept of like playing these characters
and kind of having fun with it and then
the second one
was a lot of graphics so we made sure
that you know because at that time
nobody was even trying to
book out a spot or that's this thing so
it was like you know we had a maneuver
to try to make it happen
it's been it's been more relaxed lately
i feel yeah it's kind of getting into
i see people kind of maneuvering a
little more but yeah a couple of months
ago
you already know how was the you just
did a show in oklahoma right
yeah um i don't know what the by the way
shout out oklahoma
great weed state now yeah a lot of
dispensaries there
uh i went there to do a weed show
actually i was gonna ask you like what
was that like
doing a show during these times was it
like
social distancing like yeah it was and i
was a little nervous at first but you
know they made it very clear that
you know i could they had a spot for me
that was kind of away from everybody and
i didn't have to do
um some of the obligations that i had
agreed to
originally before like the meet and
greet
kind of like sitting down and judging
some of the [ __ ] you know some of the
things that i just naturally would go do
at the wheat events
um it ended up just beating me it just
ended up being me and papa
and my boy peanut popping up and
um you know kind of just staying ducked
off in the room jumping on stage and
doing the show
but i will say this like the show for me
um personally felt really good because
i'm like i hadn't been on stage
and we thought it right yeah it was
super therapeutic bro i damn near didn't
like i
like i was supposed to do a 30 minute
set i think i did 45 just off the shrimp
because i was just like
having a great time on stage and i just
realized how much i really like being on
stage so
you know they were kind of far back and
like they had them all social distance
and like you know people were
it's a weed event so you know people
were stoned and kind of just staring but
i was on stage like you know like i was
at a festival because it was right it
had just been so long
i when this [ __ ] when this concert [ __ ]
come back around and we could tour again
man it's
whoever at the first couple of shows
they're gonna be in for a treat because
people won't be going crazy they're
gonna be going for
bro are you guys worried about like uh
because you know live nation announced
that um
they're gonna cut artist pay next year
are you guys like prepared
to like make less money from promoters
or
or maybe because i feel like at the very
least
uh a lot of venues are gonna close right
and a lot of promoters
are gonna like i don't know how many are
gonna survive especially like the
smaller promoters
and then i don't know how long it's
gonna take for people to be super
comfortable like
[ __ ] it i'm gonna pull up to a show you
know what i'm saying even when [ __ ] is
quote unquote back do you guys think
like that might affect like
either a like the bag that you guys are
gonna get or just the structure of the
bag like hey if it sells out you guys
get a bonus i know that those already
exist but like yeah
even more so that than like usual that's
why that's why
it's kind of like that balancing you
know the [ __ ] is good for your soul
exactly and then the [ __ ] that's like
for true for the bag you know like if
you a [ __ ] like me that like
thrives off of um
the fans energy you know being able to
get on stage and get off stage and then
[ __ ] with the fans is everything for me
you know that's how i keep going that's
how i keep pumping out the music but you
put the battery in
because i'm inspired by just the
everyday
struggle the everyday life people that's
just inspired that's coming out to just
all come to one place for the same thing
so i feed
i kind of need that for my spirit i
found myself kind of like
feeling a little lost at the beginning
of this because i was just like damn i'm
not used to
dropping a project and just being behind
the keyboard the whole time
yeah exactly oh it's extremely difficult
for me and like my store was shut down
you know and i'm just like this is just
didn't feel right you know what i'm
saying so it's really i think once them
shows come back you know if
as long as you can make some money where
you can walk away with some money and
you're not losing money
it's a dub to me what's your [ __ ] yeah
fans again
sell some merch that's it that's it and
i look at it like even with dropping
blaze with us too
it's like we see the numbers and we like
okay and we you see the comments of
people saying
that they [ __ ] with the music but
nothing's like going to that concert or
going to that show or really meeting
those people and
seeing how much the music is inspiring
them or seeing them singing
yeah you're like oh this [ __ ] is
knows every word of a project i just
dropped right that part for me
i'm doing this for a reason yeah that
[ __ ] will keep you going yeah and then
like getting fan paintings and [ __ ]
yeah oh yeah and i take them all home
and hang them up
i keep them all the [ __ ] i be out i
cherish that [ __ ] what was uh
dizzy you toured with tech9 a couple
years ago i did
i did and uh that's its own kind of
world right music thing and then also
just touring there
like with them like the rules are crazy
like
the bus rules and they'd be finding
[ __ ] like travis don't play
oh yeah um like i know a lot of people
who
have either just quit those tours or
gotten kicked off the tours and
yeah um how how was that experience
touring with tech9 and
just getting getting into that world and
then also kind of
just dealing with all the strange music
[ __ ] man it was like
inspiring but it was also extremely
tough you know you can't smoke on the
bus right
yeah you can't smoke the smoking on the
bus isn't what bothered me
uh i think it's the going to venues that
i went to by myself that
you know they have they have rooms for
me to smoke in
you know they got ducked off areas for
me to be you know they know they like
dizzy coming we got to make sure that we
got a fan
upstairs and we open the windows and let
them be
you know upstairs and away from
everybody and like you know some of
those places we were coming to that had
like those setups for me
uh strange music was shutting me down
and that [ __ ] was eating at my spirit a
little bit because you know i
i thrive off not having no weed problems
i know i talk a lot about weed and [ __ ]
but
it's not cool to get in trouble for the
[ __ ] you got to be smart you got to move
smart and i
i you know i dropped the album my first
album on 420 in 2012 and i ain't never
had a problem
never had a run-in with the police about
weed
not once you know in my whole career
i'm not bragging or like showing off i'm
just just trying to make it
apparent like on how serious it is you
know and
especially in some of those random
markets you'll be in and what i install
on my team
you know because it's not just me like i
ain't never had nobody on the road with
me
get into no weed trouble you know like
personally somebody that i brought
nah [ __ ] we all on the same page you
know what i'm saying for years so being
on
the road with strange music and
having doing this for so long and always
finding a way to stay
out of the way i felt like they kind of
you know they don't want you smoking in
the venue they don't want you smoking
backstage they don't want you smoking on
the bus they don't want you smoking in
the hotel so it's like
where do you want me smoke you want me
to go outside in front of me then you
might get in trouble
the fans in front of people in front of
businesses
it felt more like i was being put in
danger kind of like instead of being
ducked off
normally you know and i had i called
travis to trip with him about this [ __ ]
because i'm like man travis i'm feeling
like you don't you
you [ __ ] putting us in like dangerous
situations
he just like you know the rules
it's just like yo was that the toughest
tour to be on oh very it
very much so um very much so
uh i was inspired by tech
you know and just what he was able to
build you know i'm just so
inspired by you know him and what he was
able to do
and how he's able to get up there and
the show he's able to put on and
yeah he's really inspiring and he don't
complain
he loves what he do like it's it's not
like
you know he's not the press he's not
you know complaining he's not
drunk wilding out he's just tech you
know he's working out
he's [ __ ] but you know [ __ ]
i feel the same way i feel like i'm i'm
an easy person to work with
you know i just need to be able to you
know do my little smoke thing when i
need to do my little smoke day
and you know maybe not blow it down on
the bus where it might bring
some extra attention to other people but
you know when you're at these shows you
definitely want to be comfortable
especially before you get on stage
so it was inspiring but it was also
extremely tough for me
i can imagine um hey bro honestly that's
the thing that's like
we live in we live in l.a and vegas
people
where it's legal and you know what i'm
saying and like
when we traveling and [ __ ] like that you
get some places and
and you see how that actual state really
frowns on this [ __ ] and then imagine not
being able to smoke in the venue where
you tucked away like
anything could happen to you out there
in the streets if
if you're in one of those states and
it's a shame because six hours away you
you're good six hours away you're good
and then six hours from here you
you like oh you know so much is on the
line and something like they don't
even allow smoking outside and some of
the places where they kind of wanted us
to just kind of smoke outside
yeah you know it's not my thing you know
i i try to do well we're kind of
staying ducked off and out the way you
know i'm saying i don't need to be
blowing it down all in everybody facing
things like that you know so
but you know at the end of the day uh
strange music
runs their [ __ ] the way they want to run
their [ __ ] and it works
and they've been successful and they run
it that way so they can keep
law and order and what they got going
and you got to respect that if you want
to be a part of that i went to be a part
of that [ __ ]
it was there i mean you signed up for it
you know i signed up for now
don't get me wrong i was told that i
could do my smoke thing now
now i i i agreed to not smoke on the bus
you know i don't know if i would i don't
know if i would have signed up to not
for it to be for me to be me and my team
to be put in those kind of situations
because you know [ __ ] it was raining
and snowing what do you want me to type
of [ __ ] and they're like yo i'm gonna
get fined if i smoke in the spot that
they
that the venue says edibles i didn't i
didn't because
you might not be able to perform right
right so edibles is a
like a dangerous i like edibles when i'm
getting ready to go to sleep
you know so when i'm operating during
the day you know i just need to puff it
down a little bit i was just kind of
like
stressed out more than i'm normally
stressed out on the road you know what
i'm saying so
other than that it was all love yo look
man quick break from the podcast and
tell you about odd socks
all right they're our official sponsor
they support what we do here at the
bootleg kit podcast
all right they got the nickelodeon
joints they got these uh
yo shout out to ghostbusters i might
keep those um anyway
what you got to do is hit that
oddsoxofficial.com
if you want to support what i do the
bootleghead podcast then support our
partners odd socks go buy some socks man
holidays are coming up odd
socksofficial.com
keyword bootleg kev you're getting 20
off of the most comfortable socks in the
world
shout out to odd socks um i feel like uh
a natural thing that you and burner have
a great chemistry on records uh both of
you guys actually
um i'm curious like
burns known to drop just hella collab
projects i mean he just put out [ __ ]
with currency this year and
another be real project like he's would
have with either of you guys has there
ever been a discussion of doing like a
full
release with burner i haven't personally
talked to burner about doing the full
release i talked to him about uh
maybe like executive producing because
he his beat selection
is solid shout out to cosmo yeah cosmo
yeah that's my guy
sacramento selection is wow so i'm like
burn just pick the beast for me
yeah i mean i'll go in on some of these
because he always he always sets the
the vibe on his uh on his records the
mute the music is
songs are dope full and in its entirety
uh but his b selection is like i feel
like it's top level
do you go like dizzy obviously burn is
somebody who's kind of
another independent jug or not right
another weed jug or not you know what
i'm saying
do you um do you kind of get inspired
seeing like some of the moose burner
does
oh like a [ __ ] [ __ ] man that guy
is killing it
i love it man um
for a long time though you know no you
guys i mean he was on the warner album
like you guys have worked together for a
while
it wasn't like recently you know yeah
and uh i've been inspired by bernard for
it
for a long time but just some of the
boss moves that he making right now
it's just like you know i'm just waiting
for him to write the book
yeah you know what i'm saying so i got
the complete pieces that i need cause i
just
you know when you got that much game you
know hopefully he feels generous enough
to just
dish it out so we could all get that
kind of money
but i'm very inspired by him and i'm and
i just hope he keeps
continues to keep the right people
around him so he can stay he will
yeah he's got a very short small circle
would you ever do a uh
i think it's it'd be natural for you to
do a dizzy right or it's still moving
dispensary
in vegas oh yeah absolutely i would love
to grow into that man that's uh
you know me i'm thinking that big for
sure just gotta you just find one of the
ones that's out there struggling and be
like yo look out just
license the name i'll show up cut the
ribbon
that's it yeah cause i feel like man
that [ __ ] would be
if you have the [ __ ] dizzy right
dispensary that's the destination in
vegas put it in the air flooded that's
said
idea out there now yeah that's the show
is it uh how many you you you guys pay
for wheat anymore
either yeah sometimes and you still
gotta you know
you're gonna switch some flavors up you
know we get the pack you know but if you
just want to smoke on the packs that you
get all the time
that's cool but sometimes you know you
want to switch them flavors up a little
bit
and be able to do that you might have to
you know dish a little out
especially right now because there's so
many different strains and
dropping all the time there's always
something a new cross or something new
on the
on the cookie menu or over there yeah i
don't like not knowing the fire that's
out there yeah exactly i like being a
part of oh i love it
do you guys uh so the next thing i know
that's supposed to get legalized
i know in san francisco mushrooms are
legalized and i know that like
the idea of micro dosing mushrooms has
become more of like a um
an accepted thing amongst like yeah they
tell them
it's like it's it'll make it right i
know the guy better shark tank like
invested in a big mushroom company
uh do you guys dabble in the mushroom
game at all
the psychedelics i don't personally
i actually ain't never dabbled into
nothing but
weed weed you know i'm i'm a scary ass
[ __ ] when it comes to that [ __ ] you
wouldn't do mushrooms
it's from the earth i know and people i
know people always tell me that um
maybe but [ __ ] i don't have no desire to
or anything like that some people just
like oh it'll make you get through your
day better or maybe it'll make you look
at things a little differently and i'm
like
[ __ ] i right now i like it
yeah you know what i'm saying what about
you demmer i've done i've done shrooms
twice and i had one great experience and
i've had
one not so good experience so i'm uh i'm
like i'm
what was what happened with the not so
good experience well i just had a
i had to just a piece of chocolate i
didn't know how much it was
oh and then uh i just was watching a
movie and it felt like the person in the
movie
oh tell them the person though samuel l
jackson was yelling at me
and it tripped me out man big time and
now i was i was in philadelphia
and it was winter and you're in a row
you're in a row home in there so you
can't really get out of nowhere
and that's the first time in uh yeah
that you know homies had to sit me down
yeah relax give me some water tell me
it's all in my head type [ __ ]
and then i was like i'm not gonna judge
it off of that experience
because uh so samuel jackson was like
coming out the tv on youtube
yeah black snake moan i don't know man
he's got some that i can imagine we're
way more
intense if you're on trump but i
realized though that
you got to be able to be around a
situation where you can move freely and
it's good to you know
do it in like outside in nature and [ __ ]
like that and really enjoy the full
spectrum of the situation so i went back
and redid the experiences and it was
better yeah it was way better man i'm
like
but it's still i realize
you got to be able to like you know
people who like to have control over a
lot of [ __ ]
probably not going to like psychedelics
in my opinion because
you don't got no [ __ ] control over
that you know your mind started going
where it's going and
you got to go with it hit the button and
just go you panic you'll get a bad trip
or some [ __ ] like that and that's what
that's what always made me like i feel
like i'll be one of them [ __ ] that'll
start panicking
like and i don't want to take no
[ __ ] chances so i don't do [ __ ]
have you ever had a bad like edible
experience
i had i actually had like a bad like
bung rip
experience like wow yeah like i had
too much just
trying to hit one of them big ass bongs
trying to just
be the biggest donor i can be at the
time and i must have
cleared it i'm dizzy right yeah i must
have cleared that [ __ ] and
you know i i just you know this was back
in the front volume days like
hopsin and swizz was wearing those
contacts
and that [ __ ] was just too much for
me and then i remember hopsin took one
of the contacts out it was like
[ __ ] with you i look like a devil or
some [ __ ] and i was like oh i think
hell no i need to go to sleep and wake
up and start over again like i tried the
highest you ever been it was the highest
that i ever been
where am i what about you denmark what's
the highest highest i ever been was
was last uh november in europe
uh exhibit always like
he likes to put a block of hash and cut
a snickers bar open and put the block of
hash in there and then
close it up and eat it eat it oh [ __ ]
and so for all these years of traveling
with him
i never i never uh i never tried it
and so we were all a shout out problem
he was out there we was all out there
and i said i said [ __ ] it you know this
this time i'm about to do it
and so i took a piece of the snickers
and i ate it and uh
i got back to my hotel room and i
started to feel my body
i started to feel myself like lift above
my body that's what happened to me
and uh you know and then i just i just
laid there and just let it let it happen
eventually fall asleep but i i was on
some next level uh
yeah man put that put that hashtag
snickers and eat it exhibit eats that
normally
well i'm saying like on a day off like
let's say we do six seven
day off and he's like he's like [ __ ]
you know hey i'm about to make the
snickers with the hash and
who wants a piece typically i i would
always be like nah
i'm cool you know did you feel like you
had superpowers at all when you had the
edibles like that because like
i had an edible once and uh
it was a really rough night for me it
was a ritz and yellow of concert
and i felt like i could hear everybody
talking in the concert
i could like hone in and like
there was like two thousand people in
this venue you're not maybe maybe like
one conversation i'd be on the other
side of the venue and i like look
in the middle of a concert just look at
somebody on the other side of the
building
and hear exactly what they're saying oh
yeah you was tripping you was trapped
i don't know if i was tripping though
i felt like i was like yo i couldn't
move my legs though
i remember when i had the hash [ __ ]
like i was like [ __ ] it i feel weird i'm
about to throw on like
some youtube and watch like a little
movie or whatever and slowly
but surely the words stopped i stopped
being able to understand
what was being said in the movie right
that sounded like
[ __ ] just started like what am i even
watching like
just cut it off edibles are dangerous
because you can't like eat
to get it to go away you know you gotta
like just let the high pass
there's no other choice yeah nugget you
can't lie i tried to get in the shower
and wash that [ __ ] off i had to look at
myself in the mirror and everything i
was just like
off a bong hit though off a bunk head
bro you
are you're not a big dabber i imagine i
became a big dabber this was before
dabs was dabs you know wasn't dabbing
yet when i did this
uh and this was actually in minneapolis
i had first got wit
shout out to prince with the funk volume
[ __ ] and it was like my first time
going out there
and like dame kind of had me running
around watching what hopson was doing
you know as far as meet and greets
skating
right listen you're gonna go play skate
with fans dizzy you don't know how to
skate
figure out how to skate you're just
gonna go show up at a fan's house and
play him in skates oh
facts and [ __ ] bro but i remember
i just started making my little fans you
know what i'm saying and
i went to go smoke one of my fans and
filled the bong up and tried to hit that
big ass bong and was [ __ ] up whole
world tilted sideway
jesus i don't like being that high um
how was the experience you guys doing
the uh
the album uh a couple of years ago with
uh
audio push and uh jaren everybody was in
the house together
you're the only one who didn't show up
to freestyle by the way
everyone came to the radio station but
you blame blame
dame
hey i'm telling you if dame doesn't make
some merch that just says blame dave
he's tripping but but uh how was that
experience because that obviously
i can imagine uh i mean i feel like
staying in austin and the recording
process was great
i mean all you guys are boys audio push
the great guys shout out to price head
uh octane and yeah
it was great when we all went out there
we originally amelia rojas was there too
right yeah
we was originally gonna get in the
studio and then the studio didn't allow
smoking
so we all brought studios so we just set
our studios up at the crib
and just kind of turned it into like a
little musical trap house you know and
we
were there for the whole week and just
feeding off each other energy from sun
up to sun down
you know what i'm saying um and it was
dope then we
like we were loving the record so much
that we started going out and shooting
videos and stuff like that and like
really adding to it
it's very similar to what j cole did
some years later
with the dreamville project yeah you
just invited a bunch of people yeah when
i seen that i was like
damn we essentially did something like
that
you know what i'm saying but um the
rollout and
when when it came time just things kind
of went left field like me and damon had
a falling out
and then i wasn't a part of the
freestyles and i wasn't a part of a
bunch of different [ __ ] and i think it
took a lot of uh
momentum away from what we were doing
but as far as building it up to get it
where it was
we had a lot of fun yeah the creation
part of it just even
tapping in with with people you know
somebody producing right there
another person coming up with a chorus
and then other room people working on
the song and
some people did still go these two on
the mic man so i can only imagine like
like the friendly competition
oh yeah i had to level up every time
it's gonna be like what what you got
oh yeah oh you had you had the hardest
first yesterday so that mean
today i gotta had a hardest fan you know
yeah [ __ ] was in there he was doing it
it was a lot of fun uh
you had mentioned earlier that you you
had
attempted to meet up with dame a couple
of weeks ago what was the because
obviously you had stu
you kind of stuck with damn after the
funk volume thing what was the um
like what was y'all's issue that made
you know made that kind of split because
i remember he
stopped [ __ ] with you and it was with
futuristic for a little bit and yeah
he's doing his entrepreneur music club
thing but like what
what had happened between you two
obviously it's better now i'm assuming
or at least
on the way to being better yeah it's on
the way to being better it's definitely
i definitely don't got no uh
no hard feelings for damon nothing like
that um
i guess bro i feel like i was the one to
kind of ride with dame
definitely and then um
you know finding out that uh hopson
wasn't
making any money off of dizzy right was
kind of like
the big bang for me because you know
hopson made it seem like there was money
problems but he never said that he
wasn't making a dollar from dizzy right
you know i'm on hobson's label and i
respected hopson so much and i respected
him so much and i was very appreciative
for him allowing me to come out and do
those shows with him and
get my feet wet as an artist you know i
just wanted to get out of vegas bro you
know we was just out there all kind of
doing the same thing this is like a
little bubble i feel like it's hard to
get out it's hard to get out of it and
and not only that it's hard to get with
an artist that has like fans and a
platform for you to travel the world
right without it being like a major
artist or like having to have like
some crazy stipulations to it so i felt
like he kind of opened up his platform
to me with
open arms you know and um finding out
that he wasn't a
part of the come up with with me
financially
you know um that he was pieced out of
that
uh it just changed me and dame's
relationship
for forever because i thought dane was
the fairest [ __ ] in the world
you know but i didn't know the logistics
on
the problem and that's why me and hobson
had to have a conversation because i had
to call them like bro
did you ever make any money he was like
no and that's my fault i should have
told you and i'm like
you let three years go by [ __ ] with me
running around with this [ __ ] and you
didn't let me know
thinking that this [ __ ] was the fairest
[ __ ] in the world um
and it kind of blew my mind when i you
know i had to just accident like
was hopsin cut out and just like yeah
you know because
you pretty much felt responsible for
for finding me and giving me the
opportunities even though it was
hopsin's platform we was using so
i just felt some type of way about that
[ __ ] and i wanted to like
um separate myself from that what i
didn't do is i didn't
say anything to and i didn't like
make it a big thing i didn't get on my
hops and [ __ ] and jumping
and being like yo [ __ ] this [ __ ] i'm
not [ __ ] with him no more
i just stopped [ __ ] with him and
started doing it i'm gonna move
accordingly now
but a lot of people felt like dame was
still in
um my corner kind of helping me out and
i seen the fans responding to a lot of
things thinking that dame was the one
moving with me
when i was moving by myself for so long
so um
i just felt like the best way to get out
of that was to just keep working
you know just keep working and keep
doing things for myself but uh
yeah it was a tricky little situation
was that was that the same i mean i
don't know if you know this or not
because
i'm not trying to but was it was that a
similar situation with jaren you think
where
like did you know if hopson saw anything
off of jiren i don't know
i don't know to be honest um i always
thought we all had similar deals
and that's why i always thought it was
fair and i
i just thought that what was fair hobson
didn't think that was fair anymore
so that was always weird hey from his
perspective totally right from his
perspective totally because he deserved
to have
a team behind him instead of just one
person so i completely understand paying
one person for what a team could be
doing and getting one person's results
instead of a team results
could make you feel like that so uh i i
definitely
i definitely just learned a lot from
that [ __ ] bro and then going into doing
still moving
uh records my own label and [ __ ] like
that at first i was going to
do it with dame and then um
i just learned more about the business
and as i was learning about the business
and i don't want to
like make it seem like i'm throwing dame
under the bus because we're past this
and um and i feel like you live and you
learn right
like um i have no hard feelings or
anything but at the time oh yeah i was
salty than a [ __ ] you know what
i'm saying because i felt
like i had role with somebody and i
didn't know the full
truth and i didn't know how to feel
about that damn
yeah that's crazy shout out to i mean i
like i said i'm just happy that
at the end of the day like there's some
sort of
road map to everyone just talking again
i guess
yeah i think everybody everybody could
have did better and everybody still can
do better so you never know where it
could go
all right so the album is out uh go
support it
do you guys if was this a one-off with
smokers club are you guys going to be
doing more stuff with them because i
know you guys are obviously
you know i know you got hella [ __ ]
coming out and your
album is getting wrapped up right yeah
yeah i'm about to drop another album
uh this i wouldn't say wouldn't lock it
down as a one-off you know shout out to
smokers club we feel like they've been
um extremely tapped in with us
and supportive to what we got going on
so maybe we can run it back
you know what about uh
denmark i know with the serial killer
[ __ ] you have another
shout out to yo can we announce the tony
chalk demick ep
let's go tony chalk bring your
vietnamese ass on camera real quick
let's go man let's get it
tony chalk i happen to manage tony chalk
by the way
shout out to tony yeah we're about to
tap in but uh yeah so
your album is done or is almost done
done okay we mastering it today
who can you tell us who's going to be on
the album um
chevy woods would be on there shout out
to chevy shout out to my boy chevy woods
i love a cook chevy woods
yeah he's a chef who is he oh my god
yeah and they have his uh is it
cooking with chevy like yeah yeah he's
like kind of he'd really be feeling
himself
i gotta tap in it's tough we'll pull up
man yo next time you come to the studio
bring some of them homemade dishes you
feel me
right that part uh so that album is
coming out
anything like do you have like any sort
of idea um next month i'm gonna drop it
next
month um i also got beans on there
um beans uh aces grilled beans
yes from uh the netflix show from the
netflix she's fire
yeah yeah we just did a video too so we
got a video um coming called sick of
complaining i'm excited about that
i say just working with different
artists staying creative you know and
staying inspired by uh
people's hunger damrick um when is
serial killers four coming out it's
it'll
it'll come it's called a summer sam so
it'll be out uh sometime next month so
we were we still locking in the uh exact
date but it's for sure coming out uh
in september what is uh i know demick
you'd be doing a lot of writing for a
lot of artists like when you do that
like is it uh
do you ever like like how how do you
approach that creatively
compared to when you work on your own
[ __ ] it's really the same
process but i just think kind of like
tapping into the the energy that you
know the goal that that artist is trying
to get accomplished and just trying to
more essentially right uh get creative
with that person
you know and kind of just keep that in
mind of the direction that they're going
to go but
i'm one of those people that i like to
make music i can make a lot of music hit
the studio and just
get creative so if one day some it's we
going down this lane next day we're
doing some stuff for
some television and film or if i'm
plotting on something that i want to do
then i'm just always putting the plan
together really is it still like
extremely uh taboo to like
ghost right or like if you're like a
rapper and you have a ghost writer
i just i don't know i don't think so
just because i just feel like
songwriting is songwriting you know
people get i feel like the drake thing
kind of made it like a little bit more
okay even though he got [ __ ] for it at
first but now it's like yo fam drake's
still the biggest rapper in the world
because the fans made it clear that they
don't care yeah and like low-key
if you go back to like kanye's first
album rhymefest wrote jesus walks
yeah and people didn't give a [ __ ] and a
lot of those people be in the room would
get creative you know there's some
people that like to sit in the room by
themselves and
and they got the whole plan on how to
get to a to z
and then there's other people that like
to get creative with people you know i'm
one of those people that that's why i
have a
a lot of projects with different people
because you know whether it's a producer
or different artist and i'll be in
groups and then also
even when i do my solo [ __ ] i kind of
like team up with certain people to do
it because
i like the team effort of creativity you
know it's like
i don't think that i ever was you know
sitting in there
just writing you know writing raps all
by myself you know saying i was just
gonna change the world like that it was
something that i always did with my
homies that i always did with other
creatives
and i feel like um it's
it's helped me in this industry dude you
know just be able to
hop on some with somebody's team and
then also do my own thing
and then do like it's you know the [ __ ]
with hopper you know yeah that's it
that's
oh i love i love tapping in with with a
producer and uh
kind of working together on a on a
vibing and energy and that's how you get
stony point one and two and blaze with
us
one and blaze with us two and uh serial
killer is the fourth one
and right remember i came i came from a
group so that that that always has just
been
in my heart i guess the way i create
wait which group did you come from
i was i started early in a group called
tangled thoughts so we
live in philly and we moved out to la
together and we actually released a
corrupt presents
album with about with that group in 2007
right so that's how far back it goes
damn i didn't know that so you were like
rolling with the corrupt [ __ ] back in
the day that was it that's how that's
how i even knew to come
come out here to la because we were
hitting all the ceilings in in philly
and it just didn't feel
just didn't feel real you know it didn't
feel like we could take it to the next
level so to get the opportunity to come
to la was
that was it and especially with somebody
you know at that time at that point
corrupts already
legend you know you grew up man let me
tell you something streets as a mother
is one of the most slept on albums of
all time oh man that [ __ ]
and roscoe his brother yeah is [ __ ]
fire
yeah yes exactly like he could like rap
rap both of them can rap rap but like
i mean obviously you know it's just it's
crazy when you think of corrupt and like
how
like i always remember on the m m show
when eminem like named all those rappers
that get put ahead of him like corrupt
was one of them red man but
i i just i guess i wish corrupt's career
would have shaken out a little bit
differently
hey bro but if you look at the plaques
and them records that he's no for sure
i'm like
damn like there was a point in time
where he was on everybody's album that
like so many
good and shout out to corrupt moon rocks
uh hello
those moon rocks ain't no joke and
they've been booming for a long time
yeah uh last question dizzy this for you
uh logic just retired to be with his
family obviously
i know you're a big family guy like
could either of you guys ever see
uh yourselves just stepping away from
hip hop stop making albums
just like i'm done
i personally can't see it right now for
me um
just that's why you got to just do
things for your soul man you got to make
sure
you know i was there i seen logic's
whole
you know i was even on tour with him and
i really just
you know i watched how he moved i paid
attention i'm an observer you know you
really got to
move at your pace and and and make sure
you're doing things that's right for
your spirit
you'll get into a position and it'll be
overwhelming
you know what i'm saying and i feel like
you'll find yourself
needing to step away or take a breather
i don't think logic's done
forever i think logic just needs a break
from all the
the judgment that comes with hip hop oh
yeah he's getting mad
you know and he's been getting it for a
couple of years man ever i feel like
ever since the everybody album came out
and he kind of started to
talk about his biracial rule like it's
been on since then on his head bro it's
been oh he ain't been getting no slack
from there and it was already tough for
him before then
um just with the stigma of being like a
white rapper and you know
yeah but i'm also i'm i'm biracial right
but you know he wants to be
known for what he is so
not to get too deep or go too off
subject but i personally can't see
myself uh
stepping away right now i want to keep
inspiring and i feel like i'm getting
better
right yeah what about you could you ever
retire
i don't think so i'm always going to be
involved in this [ __ ] in some kind of
way i mean this is
this gave me life gave me purpose
right it's like once i started doing
music i fell in love with it then i had
a direction in life before that i just
was
i just was out here so i think that
um i i could see myself in the same
thing like i
i see myself i i gain more fans more
attraction
uh get more opportunities and understand
even
my story better about what i want to
talk to people about as
the years progress you know i i still
got to i wake up every day
trying to get behind the mic or or at
least find a play to do with some music
that i got going or something so
my mind's in the game but different
levels you know what
see you might catch me behind making a
beat one day you never know
come on yeah for sure
all right well look uh go get the album
it's out you guys each got a lot of new
music coming out too
soon any more videos gonna be coming out
from the project or this last one was
like
was that the last one yeah don't worry
it was like the
the last one the finale kind of the bow
on the campaign yeah well we dropped
four so we got
we got all night we ain't the same
medicated
and now um don't worry don't worry it
was like the biggest
streaming record right it was yeah it
was boom
well yo go get the project thank you
guys for checking in as always and uh
yeah man denmark dizzy right blue
lakehead podcast
boom face